ici c'est des beaux poissons c'est
l'heure du marché pour le chef
Jean-Christophe Poirier poisson
charcuterie fromage qui se retrouveront
dans les assiettes de son restaurant de
sainte-lorraine qui vient de recevoir
une étoile Michelin ça m'a pris quelques
jours avant de réaliser qu'est-ce qui
est arrivé donc
c'est bien pour l'équipe c'est bien pour
pour le restaurant c'est bien pour
Vancouver aussi
et pour le chef qui réalise ainsi un
rêve c'était toi les la consécration
d'une carrière commencée il y a 25 ans à
Montréal avec notamment deux ans au
prestigieux toqués avant le départ pour
Vancouver en 2004 là la carrière de
Jean-Christophe Poirier décolle grâce à
son travail acharné dans plusieurs
restaurants et l'ouverture du centre
Lawrence en 2017
un restaurant à l'image de ce québécois
originaire dès Laurentides simple
authentique chaleureux si on rentre dans
le restaurant et puis on est transporté
soit au Québec ou en France et puis je
vais mettre ma touche personnelle donc
les antiquités les photos de ma famille
de moi ou de mes enfants sont un peu
partout
comme ça je me sens chez moi
45 couverts une équipe de dispersion et
un menu qui réinvente des classiques de
la cuisine française à la sauce
québécoise avec un ingrédient roi
et beaucoup utilisé c'est un peu aussi
que ma touche québécoise sur la cuisine
française par exemple je peux faire une
crème caramel au foie gras mais au lieu
de sucre je remplace par le sirop
d'érable et aussi en janvier février
mars on fait un menu sur des rames
des recettes que Jean-Christophe vient
de publier dans un livre
depuis son ouverture le Saint-Laurent
collectionne les prix dont celui d'être
sur la liste des 5 meilleurs restaurants
du Canada sa clientèle est fidèle
Michelin c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
qu'on a ici c'est parfait je poche assez
la deuxième mais si elle vient c'est
parce qu'on fait un travail formidable
un travail formidable que
Jean-Christophe Poirier veut poursuivre
se concentrer sur son restaurant
améliorer la qualité du menu et
continuer à offrir du bonheur tous ceux
et celles qui poussent la porte du sac
Laurent
ici Catherine François Radio-Canada
Vancouver